So far most of what
we've been focused on has
been Europe and some of
you all have argued that,
"Hey, why is this called
World War I? It should
be called Europe War I." In reality,
especially because the
major European powers
had these empires throughout the globe,
it really was a world
war. The most significant
fronts were the Western
front and the Eastern front,
but we have many, many, many other fronts,
many other campaigns. A
lot of these helped shape
the modern world,
especially the world of the
twentieth century. You had
fronts, campaigns in Africa,
between the various
colonies that the empires
had in Africa. You had a
front here in the Caucasus
between the Ottoman empire and Russia.
You had Japan involved.
Japan, in World War I
was on the side of the
allies. It wasn't one of
the major actors in World
War I, but it helped
provide naval support,
it helped against some
of Germany's colonies in
the pacific and in China.
What I really want to
focus on in this video
is in some ways one of the
most interesting campaigns,
or I guess several
campaigns of World War I,
because it really helped shape the modern
Middle East and a lot
of the way countries are
shaped now and a lot of
the conflicts we now see
in the Middle East to
some degree can be tied
to what happened leading up to World War I
and what happened after World War I.
Just as a little bit
of context, this entire
region right over here,
what we consider to be
the Middle East now, especially Arabia,
was nominally under Ottoman control.
The Ottoman empire had
been losing power for
centuries leading up to
the twentieth century,
especially if you look
at the Arabian Peninsula.
It wasn't direct Ottoman
control. It was very
hard to control the
various Arab tribes there.
Egypt by this point, as
we enter into World War I,
in the late 1800s the
British occupied, began
to occupy Egypt, essentially
took control of Egypt.
As we enter into World
War I, Egypt is officially
a protectorate of the British empire.
Egypt is, for all purposes, it is British.
Egypt is of huge
strategic interest at this
point in time. In fact,
it continues to be of
huge strategic interest because it has the
Suez Canal. The Suez
Canal is right over here.
It's a man-made canal,
made in 1869 by the French,
and it connects the Mediterranean Sea with
the Red Sea. To see its
importance, you just have
to look at the map at a more global scale.
It's the fastest way to
get from Europe by ship
into the Red Sea and into the Arabian Sea
and to India, which was
a significant part of
the British empire there,
or to go further East,
go into the Indian Ocean and
go to places further East.
It was of huge, huge,
huge strategic interest.
That lays the groundwork
for, essentially, the
various campaigns. Oftentimes
they would be collectively
called the Middle East
campaigns, or they're
separated sometimes as the
Sinai and Palestine campaign
and the Mesopotamia campaign.
Mesopotamia, that's in modern-day Iraq.
The Sinai Peninsula, that's
part of modern-day Egypt.
Palestine in 1914, what was
then considered Palestine,
is now part of Israel,
part of the West Bank,
part of the Gaza Strip, part Lebanon.
As we'll see, all of these
countries that we now
recognize as different countries,
Lebanon, Jordan, Syria,
these were all kind of
carved and shaped by
what happened during World War I
and at the end of World War I.
As we get to the beginning,
right at the outset
in 1914, the British
land right over here at
the southern end of Mesopotamia.
Over the course of the war they just keep
driving northward along the Tigris River.
They keep driving northward and northward
and northward. By the
end of the war, they've
essentially captured
what you would consider
most of modern-day
Iraq. For the most part,
it was a very successful
campaign for the British,
although they did have
some significant setbacks.
In particular, at the end
of 1915 you have the British
who are held up in Kut.
They were essentially
sieged by the Ottoman
empire, 147 days siege.
After the 147 days they had to surrender.
They were starving in there.
They couldn't get supplies.
They were dying of
sickness. This is actually
a picture of an Indian soldier
after the siege of Kut,
after they were taken
by the Ottomans after
they surrendered. Even
though the Mesopotamian
campaign was successful
for the British, the
siege of Kut is recorded in
British military history,
or global military history,
as one of the biggest
humiliations for the
British army, where you had
that many troops who had
to surrender. They were
starving, literally, to
death. One thing I should
point out: I'm going to be
talking about the allies,
the British troops, but
in the Middle Eastern
campaigns and the Sinai
and Palestinian campaign
and in the Mesopotamian
campaign, Indian troops,
which were part of the
British empire, played a
significant factor,
especially in the Mesoptomian
campaign, and so did the Australian and
New Zealand troops. When
we talk about British
troops, we're also talking
about all of the various
nationalities that were
part of the British empire.
By 1918, they were able
to capture much of what
is now modern-day Iraq, or
much of I guess you could say
Mesopotamia. On the other side of, I guess
you could call it on the Egyptian side
of the campaign, the
first few offensives were
actually taken by the
Ottomans. They say, "Hey look,
the British hold the Suez
Canal. If we could take back
the Suez Canal, that would
be a pretty crippling
blow for the British,
especially in their ability
to get to the various
ports of their empire."
So in 1915, you have
the Ottomans try to make
an offensive to try to
capture the Suez Canal.
It's repulsed. It fails.
They try again in 1916.
That fails again. After
that, the British then
take the offensive. Once
again, it's the British,
but we're talking, they
have Egyptian troops,
they have Arab troops;
well, Egyptians are Arabs.
They have Australian troops with them.
They have Indian troops with them.
They start to make an
offensive. That offensive
essentially continues
through the course of
World War I. In 1915 they are
able to defend the Suez Canal.
In 1916 they defend it
again. By 1917, they're
making an offensive. After
several tries, they're
able to take Gaza in 1917.
Then they're able to take
Jerusalem, which was
kind of a major source of
prestige. Obviously
Jerusalem has a thousands
of years history of
various armies trying to
take Jerusalem. Then they
continue on and as they
saw that the end of the war
was imminent, especially
as we get into 1918, the
British were, and the allies
were, essentially on a land
grab. They knew that as
soon as an armistice is
called, it's kind of your
last chance to grab more
land, and then it goes
to the bureaucrats to
start negotiating things.
So in 1918 the British
are essentially on a
land grab, especially the allies.
They take Damascus. They
get all the way north
to Aleppo. By the end
of 1918 you essentially
have the end of the war.
You have an armistice
at the end of October
with the Ottoman empire.
We know that the Austro-Hungarians signed
their armistice in early
November, and so do
the Germans and World War I is over.
Now, there's a bunch of
interesting things here
and I'm kind of doing
a very broad survey of
these campaigns. One is the famous movie
Lawrence of Arabia. It
took place during these
campaigns. This is a
picture of of T.E. Lawrence,
who was many, many, many
things, but he was this
interesting character
who helped the Arabs rise
up against the Ottomans,
against the Turkish rule.
He was heavily involved
in helping to coordinate
the Arabs' uprising against the Ottomans.
In this case, the Arabs
were helping the allies
essentially push the Ottomans back.
The most interesting
thing, the outcome of this,
and we'll probably talk
into a lot more detail
about this in future
videos, is because by the
end of the war you have
the allies in control
of all of this territory
... in control ... let me do
that in a better color
... in control of all of
this territory, right
over here, it was really
left to them to carve up
the modern Middle East.
It was agreed to ahead
of time that the French
would gain control of what
is now Syria and Lebanon.
This is roughly, Lebanon's
right over there.
Syria, we're talking roughly this region,
including Damascus, so
roughly this region right
over here, and it left
the British in control of
what is now Israel,
Palestine, Jordan and Iraq.
As we'll see as we go
into the 1920s, this was
all part of the British
mandate. They carved
it up and a lot of their
decisions have led to
a lot of what we now see
as the modern Middle East,
and the French essentially
were in control up
here in Lebanon and Syria as
part of the French mandate.